performers you may recognize he's a
winner of the america's got talent
who's gone to create a successful career
and a residency at the linc
hotel and casino here's matt franco
because after all what's the holidays
with a little magic
ho ho merry christmas happy holidays
if you haven't noticed i am not santa
i'm matt franco
and thanks for being with me on this
very sunny christmas it's one of my
favorite holidays
and since i was a little kid the only
thing i asked santa for
was a deck of cards every year a deck of
cards and you know what
i'm glad i did because it eventually
took me to
here in las vegas in fact till this day
it's all i ask for my wife says matt
what do you want for christmas i say
how about another deck of cards and you
know what for good reason
i can show you some really cool stuff
like this
when you snap like that you actually get
four aces to appear almost as if by
magic we can use any cards but aces will
be just fine
hearts diamonds spades and clubs
watch now we'll start very simple all i
do is i leave one ace
on the table three in the hand i'll show
you how to make one ace travel we use a
secret tekken
technique in magic called palming all i
do is i palm the card like this you
don't see it from this side
or this side because it's invisible but
it is there you take it all you do is
you set it down next to the other ace
i know it seems impossible stay with me
we have the red ones here
and that leaves on the table the two
black aces
which will stay on the table so we now
have hearts and diamonds
hearts is next watch closely i palm the
ace like this
and all you do is you set it down right
there on the table
that leaves just one left please settle
down it's just a card trick
the ace of diamonds is the most amazing
this time you can see
three aces here on the table
and this looks about like the right spot
all you do is you set it down give it a
rub
nothing happened yet okay nothing
happened yet because i forgot to do the
riffle it's not until i
do that that it turns invisible you
can't see it there but it's there
without even touching you wave like this
and that's one two three four aces
what please settle down relax i can see
you clapping at home
oh my god standing ovation thank you oh
my god over in summerlin and henderson
too thank you very much i appreciate it
but let me tell you with these four aces
you have to be kind of careful
because if you deal them in the face
down position you can see them
but the crazy thing is when you try to
do it face
up for example because they start to
disappear
in real time they're actually just gone
completely
my friends thank you so much for
watching my silly little
situation my silly little demonstration
i don't know if it's a situation i don't
know what it is
all i know is i'm excited for the
holidays and they're here just around
the corner
and i'm sorry you had to see that matt
franco out thanks for watching
oh my god she is so good i'm sitting
here on the edge of my seat like
wait how did he do that but you can
watch matt along with several other acts
tomorrow this will be great to watch
after you finish opening all those
presidents right
and so it's going to be the very sunny
christmas special right here
on eight news now at noon perfect timing
and at 6 30.
right and what an awesome thing to see i
mean i'm trying to i thought he was
going to give the secrets away but no
magician does that but it's just like
where do those cards go i
you know under his heart that's what
makes him a magician right i can't wait
to watch more of that
wonderful well again mark your calendar
it's tomorrow at noon
and 6 30. so be sure to tune in with the
family and so it's the story of a young
saxophone player and an aspiring career
woman
who aren't letting time and space keep
them apart
coming up we sit down with the actors
behind the characters of sylvie's love
in today's entertainment report and a
classic disney tale coming to life on
the big screen a look at the remake of
pinocchio
next i'm staff sergeant baka station at
cjtf oir
i want to wish my family back in las
vegas nevada a merry christmas
i love you guys take care and i'll see
you soon
[Music]
with thousands
the auto mall
you're watching eight news now live at
four well silvie's love is a period
drama about a relationship that was
meant to be
it starts creeds tessa thompson and
former oakland raider and
nfl pro bowler namdi ahsamuah
doug kolk had a virtual sit down with
them in today's entertainment report
[Music]
tell me about this new boy at the store
hey what's your favorite song in this
you don't know what love is
i am not answering that is he cute i
didn't really notice
guys i got to be honest as soon as the
film starts i see knobby awesome one i'm
like
the football player that's tipped and
intercepted by awesome
i did do a wikipedia search i see you're
married to carrie washington you're an
actor
congratulations i appreciate it i'm glad
that it shocked you right there
controls yeah it's like i remember you
like picking off tony romo you know
play action buys a ton of time and then
the pass
is almost caught and then intercepted
juggled by martellus bennett
and intercepted by mandy asawa
now you're on my big screen it's funny
because like once the trailer for this
film went out i started getting a lot of
text
like from people that are in my life
saying
wait you're an actor when did you become
i'm like what are you
doing you know so it's anyway it's great
life's too short to waste time on things
you don't absolutely love
but how do you know if you love
something absolutely i guess when it's
the only thing that matters
the film is about uh what happens when
you meet the right person at the wrong
time
the van got off at a gig in paris come
with us on tour
i'm afraid i can't but i think you very
well could be the next john coltrane
what are you going to be two people
that fall deeply in love and have to
figure it out through
time distance um
namdi help me why should i hire you
because i didn't know that a negro woman
television producer even existed
and all my life that is all i've ever
wanted to be it's been a long
time they fall in love over a summer
they go their separate ways and they
they bump into each other again and they
realize that they still have
sylvie what are you doing in new york
recording an
album so good to see you you too
i love like the the hair whip that you
i love the hair yeah yeah that's right i
just gotta get out of the way you know
yeah that's it and they realize that
they have they still have feelings for
each other and how are they gonna figure
it out
pleasant experiences ahead don't pass it
back
bianca by the way big fan she'll talk
about it in a second
sylvie's love available to stream on
amazon prime video right now and i think
all of us are surprised that he's
married to carrie washington you know
that
that was a little factoid there huh
former nfl player
totally didn't know that but had the
tissue ready if you watched that movie i
was i was tearing up
but now on to some other entertainment
news tom hanks is talk
as taking the on the west in his latest
film
news of the world hanks plays a
traveling news reader who
is crossing paths with a ten-year-old
girl he
takes was taken away from her family he
agrees to escort the girl
across texas but their trip turns into a
fight for survival
news of the world hits theaters tomorrow
my name is something to check out with
the family
and a new imaging imagining of the
treasured classic pinocchio is coming to
the big screen
oscar winner roberto bonini
stars as the father of the puppet turned
real boy
the live action remake follows him from
one misadventure to another
it's also coming to theaters tomorrow as
well
we are going back to america oh hell no
your majesty
everyone probably remembers that movie
and eddie murphy he's returning to
turning to the screen newly crowned king
akim for more than 30 years later in
coming to
america the king returns to queens new
york where it all began
to reunite with his long-lost son
arsenio hall and james earl jones also
they are back in the movie as well
coming to america streams on amazon
prime march
5th we gotta wait
all right well we don't have to wait for
a christmas eve it is upon us
ashley conroy is in for ted track in the
weather and we're talking about clouds
here for santa right ashley
well they say baby is cold outside right
and we are seeing that right now
it is cold and it's cloudy outside
looking at our temp it is 47 degrees
currently
those winds nice and light coming from
the southwest at three miles per hour
you can see we're even three degrees
colder than we were
this time yesterday we were about 50
degrees so our temperatures are really
locking in
to feel much more burr at least for us
here in the southwest right
uh so 47 here in las vegas we're seeing
41 in reno
we're only about six degrees warmer 34
there in cedar city 58 in phoenix 62
los angeles 55 in san francisco also
some colder temps
were holding up regionally as well of
course we have those sun
rises that are happening later our
sunset happening
earlier at least when we hit that
official december 21st
mark then we'll start to see those days
get longer as we head into the new year
4 30 you can see that sun still setting
over the horizon so things are going to
be getting darker
lights twinkling more on the strip
looking at our satellite radar map we
have some showers happening
in the los angeles area lots of clouds
moving throughout our region but if we
look at
we take away the satellite portion and
just look at the radar map you can see
unfortunately those showers are only
locked into the la area
not pushing up through our area and of
course our entire region can
always use that rain so plenty of clouds
we're going to see tonight
for santa and we're going to see
again those chilly overnight
temperatures tomorrow waking up to
sunnier skies great day to head outside
still will be quite chilly there at just
59
we're looking at let's see i believe it
is 59 degrees for our high tomorrow so
chilly and sunny if you head outside
make sure you grab your jacket our
overnight lows 37 degrees
nice light west wind whenever we see
those north winds it gets a little
colder
but again it is going to feel chilly for
us here we're right about normal of
course
at 38 degrees for overnight lows 58 58
59 for our high tomorrow somewhere in
there
looking at right about average or a few
degrees above average and our extended
forecast of course we're all
happy christmas is moving through let's
see if we can get our graphics to
advance here ah there we go
and then we're going to have some
potential for bianca rain chances
sunday overnight going into monday
morning so that'll be a nice welcome
change back to you
yes we'll definitely need that and we
want to help you ring in 2021
safely here on channel 8. our awesome
team will be taking you through every
time zone starting in the
times square in new york and ending
right here in vegas
we'll be live from stadium swim inside
the circle
downtown las vegas with performances
from zoe bowie the eli
young band and other strip headliners
will of course be social distancing
doing covet screenings and following all
the guidelines
we're also raising money for our food
banks across the
country with the super bowl of caring
our goal is to hit
1 million meals any money you donate
will stay right here in vegas
the show kicks off just before nine
o'clock looking forward to that just a
week away
coming up right here on the valleys news
leader there are christmas displays
and then there are christmas displays so
we'll show you more of this incredible
show
plus the local spot shining bright this
christmas eve
care and nevada state bank you're
watching
eight news now five to four so david
there are christmas light displays and
then there are all
out christmas light displays and there's
a house in texas
that is quite the crowd pleaser
photojournalist ed
louder takes us there so we moved into
this house five years ago we built this
house
and one week after we moved in we had
our first display up and that first
display was 2500 lights
and we've gone from 2500 lights to 70
000 likes in
five years i always say i'm ocd obsessed
with christmas or christmas obsessions
there so
i call it a storybook christmas so every
section of our yard has a story behind
it so i
glue all 10 000 lights because yes 10
000 lights are hot glued onto the house
individually
oh i've got burns up and down my arms
somebody told us that doing christmas is
going to get a little hectic but i
wasn't expecting this
our neighbors have been fantastic so
with everything that's going on
it's just exciting it's a happy time so
it's really bringing a whole lot of joy
we get to come out and we have the best
seats in the house
the joy of the kids the kids are excited
they spin around in circles and
just like when you look in their eyes
it's like it makes you go back when you
were a kid
merry christmas and
that's a good thing during kovic it's
something to be happy about right now
i'm totally cool with it what we hear
from everybody is number one
they just want out of the house they
want to have a breath of fresh air
we got it we're up until new year's eve
we want everybody to come you know come
by and see us enjoy a moment with their
family and
you know take take a few pictures put us
on your mantel
that's pretty cool well there is a local
home giving those folks a run for their
money take a look
some pictures from the leftler family up
in the northwest
every single year they decorate both
sides of their driveway in their garage
with
santa's bears and nutcrackers of course
make sure to send us your photos of your
decorated home or your tree we'd love to
see them
get those to our eight news now facebook
page or you can email us
at pix that's pix 8newsnow.com always
great to see and of course we love
sharing them on air and
on facebook yes i just love driving
around and seeing everyone's house all
lit up
so great to see right for sure
especially when you see like a line of
homes right and the whole neighborhood's
in on it
and everybody participates just bringing
joy to everyone
so such a great time of year all right
well thanks for watching us here at 4
30.
we are always on eight newsnow.com also
on facebook twitter and
instagram and be sure to watch eight
news now at five
next after the break